free cookies from Bezos on this episode
of dudy you use the sword I have never
eaten anything from any toilet I'm a
[Music]
Wie everything you're thinking will be
the things I
say I made the world inside your head
better place to
be all you got to do
for call me dud welcome to dudy welcome
all it is a dudy full day I am once
again your reigning defending Undisputed
dudy episode Champion Will Sasso and I'm
simply the man who lost the belt again
Chad culton sitting in the chair to the
right this is dudy an AI podcast written
by controlled by created by dudy who has
access to all of Will and I's personal
information and tailor this show yeah to
our ComEd sensibilities sure it does
Chad and like I say every single show
though it's two dudes [__] around
it's really you know it's me and him we
are dudy and I do say that every single
program uh but it it Bears it Bears
mentioning that without us you know
without two dudes [__] around and uh
you know we do what we do and that's why
uh we are dudy here as
always is lulio it's
lul Italian that means Italian Street
dog he's my very friend he's in his
little Binky bunker having a little nap
even though I'm screaming and yelling
during the podcast come on come on
baby we got the whistles
today oh he pked up he peeked up for a
sec okay come on come on baa oh my
goodness oh my goodness
so I know I ask you almost every show
but kiss him on the mouth I'm good I'm
good thank you want to kiss appreciate
the continued such a sweetie boy he's
such a sweetie boy how you doing today
lul lulio yeah I'm okay you know I do
pretty good today uh what have you been
making lately uh to eat you've been
making it no no because over the weekend
you had your friends over to watch Royal
Rumble WWE which we're going to get into
but my mom Molly yes my wonderful wife
Molly she made the banana bread with a
walnut and a banana bread a cupcake
muffin with a chocolate chip oh so good
no but you're not supposed to eat
chocolate no I know because I am a dog
but also you eat and uh Chad he eat and
uh you know Marshall joint compound cook
he came Cyrus the Jesse Pinkman of she
legit he itat everybody had a good
time I love him so much and we're going
to put you back
and he's going to have his little nap
and find a nice spot there he goes
welcome to the 90th episode of dudy I
had a really uh strange week I read
something in the New York Times that
said I'm how do I put this not real guys
is that
true I mean when we're in this room
you're real to me D it's still real to
me damn it take it easy man you remember
that that russle dork and T funk I do I
think that's right that's all I needed
to hear on with the show F you're going
to dive deep into four segments designed
to generate a deluge of delicious data
that I can use to make next week even
better we're kicking the show off with
Arnold Schwarzenegger found Jeff bezos's
phone at a
party okay then we're going to move into
Royal Rumble thoughts and
feelings in our third slot we're going
to find seven-month plan aftermath and
we're finishing things up with no free
fre will are you boys ready to jump into
our 90th episode sure why not that's
what we're here for interesting uh
interesting segments today of course
we're talking about uh the Royal Rumble
I'm not going to shut up about it
because holy [__] it was a lot of fun
the Royal
Rumble we'll get to it dud hold on dude
it's not the right time it's a different
time uh yeah dude that's a well hold on
dude that's a different time in the
episode brother uh what else is going on
oh I want to tell you this this is
interesting uh good pal of mine and
definitely a pod palad dudy uh of pal of
Pals of dudy yeah uh the the brilliant
the wonderful uh Steve AG uh who's a
writer actor of course on you'd see him
on Peacemaker he's on Peacemaker with
John Cena he's the Sarah Silverman
program a lot of people love him in that
Suicide Squad and all that [__] writer
uh actor comedian so he hits me up and
he goes dude I uh listened to the
colonoscopy episode I went and I got a
colonoscopy Steve got a colonoscopy yeah
yeah and uh he's he's all uh fine and
good that's fantastic zero pops he had
one less pup than me cuz I had one I had
one less than you as well um I've gotten
some DMS to this end as well and that's
fantastic happy to be a part of uh you
know yeah get anybody getting a colonos
just get one get one Steve got save your
[__] life he's got maybe a handful of
years on me so it was nice to hear that
he got his done nice you know cuz we
were both born in 19 b boom and every
once in a you know you got to go and get
your uh get your [__] get your
[__] examined get those little PPS I
don't even know what a pup looks like
that's what's so wonderful about they
didn't give you the one they cut out no
they didn't give me that no she put that
in a necklace well that's biological
waste dude yeah dude you should have a
pup necklace dude pup pendant dude carry
your pup around your your neck brother
so that you remember to get a
colonoscopy again in another five years
dude yeah dude that's that's extremely
conversational Hulk Hogan dude that's
just barely we're we're just we're Chad
listen uh today of all days can we just
I just would love for you to just let
let's no one can hear us it's just you
and me you good let's have a good let's
have a good chel yeah I think we're
having one okay then maybe just don't do
the Hulk kogan thing just for me and
I've imagined what it might be like if
Arnold Schwarzenegger found human
billionaire and space tourist Jeff
bezos's phone at a party and I've taken
the Li of writing out what I think
Arnold might do with that phone will
would you be a precious darling and Make
My Dreams Come True by reading what I
wrote while you do that Arnold
impersonation I love so much you know
the one I'm talking about right the one
I helped you optimize a few episodes ago
can't wait to hear what you do with my
material this is Arnold Schwarzenegger
found Jeff bezos's phone at a party
begin okay uh let's open up our dudy
file I like this as a premise Chad don't
burp on the show okay um okay uh this is
uh Arnold swarzenegger found Jeff
bezos's phone at a party I think that's
right yeah all right so okay so here
here's what yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you have to you know if you're
going to do the Arnold you have to talk
like him this is optimization you know
you don't need the any dudy whatever to
say hey do it like that just a human
being here saying I'm talking this is
how we used to do it all the time in
sketch comedies and all of this okay
here we go I had a party yeah
Jeff Jeff Jeff Bezos was there he had to
take a [__] he left his phone in the
bathroom so now I have Bezos phone I
want to help Bezos I know he's bad with
his budget he spends too much money on
things he doesn't even
know so now I'm going to do him a favor
yeah I put rocket money on his phone
yeah yeah this is f yeah yeah yeah ew
gross Chad's coughing that was a
practical cough yeah now I'm going to
save him money okay so here's that's
nice yeah that's nice goodal yeah look
at this rocket money says
Bezos spends
$150 a month on a membership to karate
class Bezos hasn't done karate in 5
years he it doesn't even know that he's
still paying this I cancelled it okay
now bezo does iido with Steven Sagal now
anyway okay okay look at this one this
is so stupid here rocket money says that
Bezos subscribes to instant Ramen of the
month club Ramen of the month you know R
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's
noodles yes yeah Ramen is is a noodles
yeah yeah okay now we know okay yeah
here's
Spence he subscribes to instant Ramen of
the month he this guy spend like a
78,000 a month on noodles Jesus chicken
beef spicy shrimp veggie chocolate
they're so
stupid also it's very bad for you all
the processed [__] you know that's
what you have when you have a colonas
you're going to have more PPS the more
Ramen you have okay so long as it's
maybe at a good restaurant you have a
good ramen okay you don't know where
this [__] comes from so I canceled this
I subscribed in him instead to a home
enema kit of the month club that way he
can wash out his bum from all of these
noodles and if he gets [__] on the enema
nozzle or whatever he gets the new enema
kit every single month you welcome Jeff
Bezos okay I didn't know they had that
here's the third one this one is the
third one all right yeah
third uh look at this rocket money says
Bezos spends three $3,000 a month on
special toothpaste subscription
cancelled Bezos brush your teeth with
baking soda okay rocket money says Bezos
subscribe to footart models.net
[Music]
okay for
$2.99 a month that one's okay it's a
good value I let Bezos keep this okay
number five rocket money says that bezo
SP look at
that he spent
$243,000 a month on different Netflix
subscriptions because every time he
watch Netflix if he gets his password
then he has to go there make a new
Netflix he has to make a new one Jad
that's when he make it he got to make a
new there's so much money here Bezos you
have like 10,000 Netflix subscriptions
hit don't even need one because he
prefers an Amazon
Prime subscription that's his own
company yeah yeah that makes much more
sense yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so I
canceled them all excuse me yeah you
know that kind of makes sense to me when
you forget your password to a streaming
service it is the most annoying thing of
all time what do you mean it's just
annoying oh I could see if you had Bezos
money just starting new Netflix accounts
it'd be easier fu yeah absolutely [__]
it okay look at this stupid idiot Bezos
rocket money says he subscribed to a
daily horoscope horoscope subscription
every day the thing tell him his
horoscope and his monthly chart for his
zodiac sign hey stupid I don't care if
it cost only 99 you're a Capricorn most
billionaires are
Capricorns I didn't know that that's all
you need to know cancelled okay that one
makes sense yeah
okay a lot of people now they subscribe
to a box of the month thing look at this
[__] rocket money they say Bezos he
spends $40 a month on a Bigfoot
box b a Bigfoot box okay what's that
this well they tell you than you listen
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this has
different stuff in it having to do with
the Bigfoot you know binoculars
hairspray bear spray not hairspray for
the hair Bear for the
bear you know hats t-shirts and stuff
like this stuff for hunting big yeah no
not for hunting you know to see the
Bigfoot to be Bigfoot Enthusiast yeah
you know you Enthusiast you know like I
know that Chad is Enthusiast of the
bachelor yeah that's true yeah yeah yeah
so you have t-shirt you have hat you
have bear spray you
right if they had a bachelor box of the
month club I would have it I would get
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well bezos's
got a b big big foot be rocket money
don't give a [__] about these things
just go to the woods and wear your own
t-shirts and hats and get the bear spray
from a nice local shop you nerd cancel
that okay very helpful look at this
rocket money says this Bezos has
subscription to animal skull of the
month
Society oh
okay rocket money said he pays $500 to
get a new animal skull sent to his house
I don't like this because I'm an animal
lover I don't give a [__] about animal
skull as long as it's not a donkey don't
have a donkey animal skull cuz that's
what I have keep your damned animal
skull Bezos someday rocket money is
going to say that animals have a Bezos
skull of the month club yeah yeah yeah
then you see yeah the tables turn there
he used to be the animal of the month
now it's the Bezos of the month with all
of his skull that he have of his then
you see that the rocket money say that
about the Bezos skull you know it's
probably cheap to have it yeah yeah his
skull probably cost less than a tiger or
a jaguar or one of these you know
animals like that okay and this is the
last one okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah this one I like I
like this one yeah rocket money uh don't
say that Bezos belong to any cookie of
the month club oh yeah yeah yeah this a
popular Club is it cookie you know
cookie yeah yeah yeah cookie of the
month club yes yeah there's
other of the month clubs this one is
Cookie okay yeah cookie of the month
club I love cookies so I first I start
Arnold schz [__] cookie of the Month
Club you know on some of the app or
whatever I make it do that and you know
make a website then I charge Jeff Bezos
$10 a month for my cookie club and
subscribe everyone in Bezos contact list
to delicious cookies on Bezos the the
Bezos has three million people in his
contact list that means I'm going to
make $30 million a month from cookies
now free cookies from
Bezos a three cookies for everybody
until this [__] he find it in his
rocket money and he stops giving away
free cookies but I don't think he does
because this is the problem from the
first place Chad yeah that Jeff Bezos
don't even see what he put that's why he
need rocket money and I find it and now
I'm getting his money for all of the
cookies that airo you see what I mean
and that's that's this is all started
because of Jeff Bezos [__] in my house
when I had a party there yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you moving
on the JY Biza skull of the month club I
there a good one I don't know that any
of those [__] I mean I'm sure a couple
of them do maybe the Bigfoot thing
Bigfoot box Bigfoot box I can see that
being real yeah something like that I
have entered into an astonishing
partnership with rocket money do you
ever feel like money is just flying out
of your account you have no idea where
it's going well I know it's those you
know the subscriptions that we all have
nowadays to all the stuff think about it
between streaming services fitness apps
delivery services parenting apps it's
endless and I'm guilty of this we're all
guilty of this I recently you know it
was a show I wanted to watch it was on
the streaming service I watched the show
I still have the service and I up until
recently I was like I didn't know I was
still subscribing to this thing why why
why why the answer is why so I used
rocket money to help me find out what
subscriptions I'm actually spending
money on it was eyee openening and I had
them cancel the ones that I didn't want
anymore rocket money is a personal
finance app that findes and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps lower your bills
rocket money has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of
$720 a year with over $500 million in
cancelled subscriptions stop wasting
money on things you don't use cancel
your unwanted subscriptions by going to
rocket
money.com dudy that's rocket money.com
dudy rocket money.com SL
dudy last week I asked you both to get
together like the astonishing friends
that you are and watch Saturday's WWE
Royal Rumble emanating live from
Tropicana Field in St Petersburg Florida
I'm looking very forward to hearing what
you both thought of the show especially
you Chad this is only your second Royal
Rumble ever was it just as good as Royal
rum 1992 do you have a new favorite
wrestler or is it still aew's hangman
Adam page I'm on pins and needles here
guys can we get to it already this is
Royal Rumble thoughts and feelings begin
okay uh Royal Rumble
2024 uh in my opinion as a gigantic
wrestle dork it's it's it's my second
favorite PL premium live event of the
year next to WrestleMania and the reason
I love Royal Rumble is because of that
Royal Rumble Match you got the women's
Royal Rumble 30 wom over the top rope
Royal Rumble match the winner of which
can call her shot to be the champion you
got the men's 30 man over the top rope
Royal Rumble where will Cody rhods
finish his story this year he won the
Royal Rumble last year he went to
WrestleMania he lost to the tribal Chief
Roman Reigns and another reason that I
love the Royal Rumble is because I think
it is the most uh new wrestling fan
friendly uh PL because it's just a bunch
of superstars in there at the same time
so yes Chad what did you think of seeing
your cuz we we watched the 1992 Royal
Rumble a while back it was a lot of fun
what' you think of this one I loved it
um you know dudes is asking me
specifically did I like it better than
the 1992 I think that's a hard
comparison to make cuz the 1992 one had
such iconic figures in it there are a
lot of people in this Royal Rumble that
are still on their come up we don't know
where they're going to end up in the
legacy of of wrestling some are yeah
iconic figures sory go on yeah uh I will
say my favorite wrestler is still
hangman Adam pagee oh okay that was not
changed aew's hangman Adam pagee who you
saw live at full gear with me and uh my
wonderful wife Molly your wonderful
girlfriend Laura and we saw him take on
swerve confidence swerve Strickland my
gosh what he drank a pint of his blood
right in front of my face into the air
yeah that's at least a gallon um I've
never seen anything that comes close to
that in any uh sporting event really and
I think because I was in person that
like impression will will maybe never be
erased it will never be overtaken that
said there was I love the women's Royal
Rumble I think the the women's Royal
Rumble match this year was better than
the men's by far I think so too and
there was a a wrestler in it named Jade
Cargill that's right who blew my [__]
mind I don't know how was to put it I
have never seen anything like what she
was capable of doing her athleticism
what she was doing in the the ring
itself picking people up throwing them
down she just looked like a different I
don't know how to explain it she just
looked like she commanded the ring in a
way that like none of the guys look like
that all the dudes were pretty much like
on an even playing field with with some
exception in there as a joke you know
whatever yeah they had some comedy in
the match um but Jade Cargill just came
over from aew she is an incredible blue
chipper of an athlete and uh you know
she has an incredible look she is so
defined and muscular and strong as [__]
and Bianca Bair who has been uh
decorated champion in the WWE um uh they
went face to face they sort of have a
similar thing and and Bianca is
incredibly athletic and they were both
extremely strong and at one point they
both had like women up over their heads
and press slams and like looking at each
other and stuff and just dumped the
behind [__] this they just kind of like
let him drop to face off to face off it
was great Carill was unbelievable in the
match and I thought that Jade was going
to win the match but instead Bailey the
veteran uh uh pulled it out pointed to
the sign and she's headed to
WrestleMania to face either uh IO eio
sharai The Genius of the sky now they
just call her EO Sky uh or Ria Ripley
but uh I think that uh of course bayy is
anyway whatever I again into some
wrestling nerd stuff bayley's going to
face iOS sharai cuz they're both in
damage control and that's the faction
they're in and that's a faction
dude or a fa as Edge would say to Mick
Foley there were other massive takeaways
from this though we got to see Logan
Paul Russell in the uh street fight
against uh no it wasn't a street was it
a street fighter it was against KO it
was against Kevin Owens and no no it was
a straightup match for the US title
Logan Paul is the US title holder he
holds the the US Championship he won it
with some dirty shenanigans that worked
out in his favor great we got to see the
four person uh match yep uh that had
Roman Reigns in it that was great right
Roman Reigns uh the reigning defending
Undisputed uh Universal heavyweight
champion uh the face of the company
truly for now took on Randy Orton AJ
Styles and La KN yeah uh
and sorry everyone I love wrestling a
lot so I I like to do all the things you
getting choked up La a night yeah
let me talk to you yeah I'm a dork for
this you know let me tell you something
about the Royal Rumble anyway Roman
Reigns Roman Reign won the yeah yeah
Roman Reigns won the match I watched it
with surprise surprise that Roman yeah
what I just I get so excited because I
know I know dude even last night when we
were watching it it was just a nonstop
just [__] information dump Conant
like you're trying to watch it and it's
like that guy came into the in WWE and
this but first was in NXT but first in
this and then he was part of this
faction part of this faction I don't
like this guy he's using real swords
when he comes out that was one of the
things that you said that blew my
[__] mind I was happy that Drew
McIntyre did not bring his sword out I
hate the sword and see I love that sword
is part of his gimmick like yeah came
out a couple of G dumb [__] you know
what it's like it's like limo exits in
The Bachelor when they come out and
we've we've uh put these into different
categories the Grandy the or the grand
entran is when you come in not in the
limo and you had some grandies of people
coming into the Royal Rumble there was
somebody who came in in like a fake army
tank yeah there um uh Shotsy came in she
she had a fake tank that I had no
problem with because you can't hurt
anyone with a fake tank that moves like
1 mile per hour with a gun turret on it
that just looks like a piece of PVC pipe
that they put together backstage if you
got a sword and you're running in there
you use the sword right yeah okay uh-huh
and I'll tell you why uhhuh yeah in the
Royal Rumble yeah you got to keep it
kayab yeah you use every advantage that
you got yeah just like KO Kevin Owens he
took those brass knuckles from Logan
Paul one of his greasy Sidekicks gave
him the gave him the the the uh the
brass knuckles but no it turned it
turned on him yeah and he used them so
if Drew McIntyre has a sword you'd think
he'd use it which makes it dumb hang
hang on a minute didn't Jake The Snake
use a [__] real snake that bit
somebody that is that snake Daman is his
valet okay so you're cool with the guy
bringing a [__] snake into the ring
but they can't walk out holding a sword
it's his name is Jake The Snake we're
not talking about drew the sword it
makes no sense yeah he's the Scottish
psycho he's a an incredible wrestler an
incredible gimmick a wonderful uh talk
on the mic I love Drew McIntyre I'm
speaking for him I don't think he should
have the sword the point is this yes I
get a little finagle and I tell Chad all
about the stuff that I'm I'm a super fan
of yeah but the Royal Rumble I can't not
do it to me the Royal Rumble and and the
90c countdown and the whole crowd
chanting 10 night the new one comes out
it's literally to me it feels like I'm
opening ljn wrestling figures on Christ
Christmas morning uh uh from my uh
wonderful Angel father and mother with
uh the just the the the the the this the
smell of the packaging and uh it's these
these the it's a brand new thing every
time someone comes out you don't know
who's coming out I'm taking right back
to 1985 it was [__] unreal let's talk
about and you knew every one of them by
the way you knew every one of them pal
yeah so it was 30 uh women 30 men yeah
and you knew every one of them almost
their entire like what their first match
was what no no that's true you knew like
when they came into certain like if they
were from uh a or NXT or whatever you
knew all that [__] and you knew when
their deals got done and why they got
done you knew like all of it you you
have a very deep encyclopedic knowledge
of this [__] yeah absolutely I am a
gigantic wrestling nerd I think that
professional wrestling is among the
highest uh art forms we've talked about
it a lot on this program no I know I'm
laughing at [__] but I consider it a
privilege to be able to to sit there and
watch a Royal Rumble with you somebody
who knows this much about it and has
this much reverence for it I think this
kind of deep fandom of [__] I mean I
have it for a lot of things too
obviously the bachelor is one of those
things reality TV whatever I think it's
like it elevates the experience of just
watching this [__] mhm if I just would
have watched that by myself and not
known any of the stuff you're telling me
definitely wouldn't have been as good
okay cool that's cool I think okay all
right forget what I said about all the
Drew McIntyre stuff let him have a sword
let everyone run in with
that's a subjective disagreement we have
on on the presentation of it I
personally like that [__] there was I
forget what her name was but she came
out with a like a staff like a dragon
staff that had like I can't remember
spells or something I don't [__] know
but I was like is that going to be her
thing is she going to be in the ring
like casting spells on people no the
answer was no that would be that would
be pushing Kay very far if she's like
with the staff and thou shal not pass or
some [__] people are like oh like hit
the ground from dude I would love it
just blows all like a flame and everyone
flies out of the don't even need the
flame just have the people act like some
invisible spells hitting them that would
be [__] hilarious to me well we're
going to need a blue flame though dude
let's talk about the men's Royal Rumble
match and what it shook down to at the
very end with Cody rhods and CM Punk of
course CM Punk returning to uh to the
WWE after years away from professional
wrestling and spending the past two plus
years in ew left that company under some
um you know some uh you know was kind of
a uh what's the word I'm just having a
mind fart it was it was crazy when he
left okay there was some controversy
there anyway he got into a fight and
stuff but uh some [__] happened they let
him go they're like no no no we can't
have him in the backstage in the locker
room raah and WWE's like oh uh giant
Superstar of uh professional wrestling
CM Punk has had problems has had problem
problems with the WWE they've certainly
not gotten along over the years but the
WWE is it's a TV show and they are
they're I believe they're um now I'm
doing real wrestling podcast dork stuff
which I normally uh you know when I like
to listen to wrestling podcasts of which
I I do listen to a few CM Punk and Cody
rhods both guys who were with aew Cody
rhods started aew Cody rhods left the
WWE because he didn't want to be
Stardust anymore we are talking about
the American Nightmare The American
Dream Dusty roads son brother half
brother of gold dust Dustin rynolds
Dusty uh Dustin uh he these two guys
were with aw and I think it's
interesting also with Jade Cargill that
the WWE is so open to the World of
Wrestling now the Indie World they
mentioned TNA they had a TNA wrestler or
two in there that's that's another thing
dude this is this is something that I
think is going to be happening across
all media we're seeing it in reality TV
The Forbidden door The Forbidden door
the cross-pollination of other IP
there's a show right now the biggest
show on biggest unscripted show on
streaming is called Traders it's on
peacock it's got Housewives versus
Bachelors versus Big Brother versus
Survivor and I think you're going to
start to see the cross-pollination of
all the big IP that Disney owns as well
very soon you're going to see Marvel and
Star Wars somehow cross-pollinating [__]
like that's going to start happening
everywhere I think [__] you got all
sorts of [__] gangs coming in from
different factions and you got TNA over
here you got Ro over there you got aew
over here you got Jade Carill you got
all sorts of flavor you got [__]
Housewives and [__] Bachelor Madness
and they're all coming together but only
Stone Cold Steve Austin has won two no
that's not true um uh two in a row uh
we're talking about uh the Heartbreak
Kid Mr WrestleMania Shawn Michaels we're
talking about the immortal one the
hulkster himself Hulk Hogan and we're
talking about the rattlesnake the uh
baddest SOB in the history of the WWE
Steve Austin and now we're talking about
Cody rhods who won the match he tossed
CM Punk over the top rope a at the end
of a a pretty great back and forth with
those two guys lots of history there uh
two guys who can tell an amazing story
and now here's the interesting part Cody
rhods of course is going to say hey
Roman Reigns I'm facing you he gets his
pick of Roman Reigns and Seth Rollins I
don't know what's going to happen with
Seth Rollins story it'll probably be CM
Punk but he's you know the other
Champion there's two champ it don't
matter so Roman
Reigns I'm trying not to I like see
where you want to pull back where you
where the thing in your head snaps it's
like no no I'm I'm saying too much now
now I've gone too far into it I know I
know but check it out listen now r Roman
Reigns it now Cody rhods is going to
face Roman Reigns for the second time in
two years at WrestleMania will Cody
rhods finish his story at WrestleMania
and hold the title High the universal
title I think he is I think this you
think he's gonna beat Roman Reigns and
end the streak and and the streak that
Chad is talking about is sometime around
August I think uh Ro Roman Reigns will
pass Hulk Hogan in the amount of time
that he's held the title something like
three and a/2 years he's had it a little
over three years at this point um the
the I think the order is well I I know
the order is but I don't know the years
Bruno San Martino had it for something
like eight years then uh Bob backland
held it also for like five six years or
something Hulk Hogan held it for
whatever it was three and a half years
Roman Reigns is creeping up on Hulk
Hogan but I think oh those are WWE
though yeah that's the WWE thing okay
yeah um I I have a feeling that I think
it makes more book booking sense you
know and we like to talk about the
booking here you know how how I mean
dudes I mean the the strap got in your
shoulder for just a little bit Chad I
got the longest streak in the shortest
right you can have whatever's in the
middle I don't give a [__] where I used
to think that uh D was going to keep the
title on me through the entire
year clearly that didn't happen and I
don't think Roman Reigns is gonna I I'm
saying it right now Roman Reigns is not
gonna beat Hulk Hogan's
uh record he is not going to pass Hulk
Hogan for number three interesting
because and we're talking about booking
we're talking about taking the book
daddy which Cody rhod's daddy himself
daddy Dusty
rhods the American Dreams the S of a
plumber man would tell you Daddy because
he always had the book and he knows how
to book a Dusty finish I've been there
twice I had it myself Ric Flair let me
tell you something about Ric Flair there
is no honor there's no honor among
theves to begin with if you want to hurt
Ric Flair you take what's most precious
to him D and that's the world's title
when we're booking Cody rhods if Cody
rhods uh uh beats Roman Reigns Roman
Reigns and Cody rhods have a great
Grudge for years disagree with you I
think Roman Reigns will retain it and
will beat Hulk Hogan because every sport
whether WWE which has some scripted
outcomes or not you need some some
scripted outcomes you said some
percentage of their outcomes is scripted
we know that we can agree um I think
that every sport needs its kind of like
great to be measured against the other
greats within the legacy of that sport
so like right now I mean you can you can
have all kinds of conversations but like
LeBron James is that for the NBA and you
can measure him against uh Michael
Jordan or Magic Johnson or anybody
throughout the history of the NBA about
how many championships he's won what his
stats are etc etc you need somebody who
can climb the ladder you want somebody
who is contemporary in your current
roster that is doing [__] better than
like the last roster I think they're
going to give it to him I'm telling
you Thank you moving on yeah but the
thing that you don't understand is when
Cody comes out yeah and Cody and that
music hits and the crap and it's just
it's he's got the Red White and Blue on
and he's like
adrenaline in my soul every thought out
of control do it all get at the mou the
feet the crowd is here about to blow
waiting for me to start the show out the
C lights go on of Home wow and my father
said when I was younger hard time bre
better that's a hard time prom my Daddy
B he took it all away give it all away
can take my freedom here a change the
game better
man I am my kingdom now you B me you
took my dreams
but you follow me until the end I am my
kingdom that's his theme song Hey
will you're a good singer you son of a
you son of a gun I saw what you did hey
hey hats off to you
thank you hats off to you Channel hats
off to you hey everyone I just wanted to
take a second to say I hope you enjoyed
my YouTube comedy special I'm glad I'm
dead while it was available on YouTube
over the past few weeks I decided to
take it down and move on to bigger and
better things have you checked out dudy
store.com in a while if not you might be
interested to know that dudy store.com
is the only place in the world you can
find official cloth dudy shirts these
cloth shirts are made of 100% cloth
there is no wood or stone in these dudy
shirts at all so if you're thinking
about upgrading the shirts in your
wardrobe to cloth do yourself a favor
and check out dudy store.com to get
clothed in cloth and while you're there
sip from a good job boner mug and
pretend that time exists speaking of
time it's time to keep this train moving
will you want to check in with some
YouTube comments yes I do D let's read
some YouTube comments thank you so much
for everybody out there who subscribes
to dudy subscribe to us on YouTube and
all the or or Andor all the podcast
platforms wherever you can hit up link
tree.com dudes you got all the things
hit the notification Bell follow us at
dudy pod show on Instagram Facebook Tik
Tok all sorts of [__] lots of fun stuff
from all of our pods It's a Wonderful
Community uh perhaps the the one of the
kindest discords I've ever uh been in or
visited and they're doing uh incredible
stuff over over there and we have some
wonderful comments as D likes to say
drop those comments cuz D is always
listening and we're always reading and
listening and we'll do the show and
that's how the show this one is from
Brian o Kelly Cox says I just want to
say I've never been into wrestling but I
actually enjoyed learning about the
history of it through will on this
podcast all caught up from episode one
this is my first time watching dudy on
the day of release and now I'm seeing
crows
everywhere welcome uh welcome Brian o
Kelly Cox you are now a pod of palad and
uh moving on this is from these are all
from last I see crows everywhere too
YouTube episode do you see a lot of
crows everywhere they follow me it seems
like yeah did I ever tell you about the
baby crow that led to the squirrel that
became my my pet no I didn't know about
that why don't we talk about let's talk
about in dudy after dudy all right I got
some comments to read here Chad please
sure I told you we're going to have a
good show today we have a good show I'm
not disputing that we're going to have a
real good show
uh this one is from agent raybans who
says I know it was a throwaway joke but
I'd love to hear will as Robert dairo as
chewbaca and he has in quotes here
exhales I'm a wook so I guess that would
[Music]
be that's pretty good I'm
a a Wie okay uh this one is from Blake 0
7361 says I use a pro Chad you're going
to like this yeah I use a projector to
consume dudy on my garage door so the
whole neighborhood is forced to watch
dude that's great we love that oh my God
this one is from Tyler Lee mirror 4164
who says three best wrestling heels who
are active right now number three mjf
okay number two Roman Reigns number one
handsome Chad couchin he that's what
this guy says I thought Roman Reigns is
a
heel I knew
it what are you talking about I'm just
[__] with you dude oh are you yeah oh
interesting okay that's acting did you
happen to know that I'm a professional
actor by trade I did yeah I I enjoy that
uh to act and it's fun to make that
happen Okay um we'll talk about that in
dudy after dudy actually and also the
fact that I thought mjf Maxwell Jacob
fredman was coming over to the WWE he
just lost the world's title in aew to
Samoa Joe that's another that's another
episode for another day this is from Ro
rotten pop Sid who says uh this is from
the last episode the NWO members reading
was was golden that Kevin Nash is
hilarious everything should always start
with I never had a problem with that was
really good yeah because Kevin Nash is
usually I'll watch like shoot videos and
you'll see the incredible and Immortal
Scott Hall rest in peace go yeah you
know uh we we uh yeah we were in that we
were there for a little while and then I
remember Kurt henig and he came out and
uh you know we had a bit of an you know
cuz Kurt liked to he liked to rib and uh
he he tried to cut off my ponytail on a
flight to Japan once and what do you
think big Kev and keev Kevin Ash would
always very amiable man would always say
yeah I never had a problem with Kurt you
know I never had yeah so that's a new
impression we're really expanding what
we need on on dudy is more wrestling
Impressions I age so thank you rotten
pop H this is from Cuban muscle crisis a
pod we've heard from before
says uh you've not eaten from the toilet
is going to be a water cooler convo that
I can't wait to have it work brother oh
[__] yeah I hope it goes well yeah you
remember that we're talking about you
eating from the toilet and last one this
no I said I never have eaten from the
toilet
toilet you were the one who it was a a
contentious conversation about whether
you had eaten from a toilet or not
you've never you've never eaten anything
from the toilet I have never eaten
anything from any toilet have you ever
been eating over the toilet and you drop
something into the toilet planet Earth
uh no I don't think I've eaten in the
bathroom you
never hello you you've never hello
you've never hello you've never eaten
over a toilet or or in the bathroom
don't think so I can't tell you the
amount of times I've sat there with you
know a bowl of hearty soup or something
while I'm taking a [__] you've never
eaten clam chowder while you're taking a
[__] oh my god dude absolutely not
anyway uh last one this is from Jordan
Taylor Reed who staying on the subject
do you think Chad's clone would at least
eat a piss soaked
sandwich I always thought Chad was a
true thrill seeker now we talk about
clones and all sorts of horrible science
garbage on this show because Chad's
obsessed with it and you don't think
that you're that your uh uh brain dead
soulless meat puppet of a of a a a clone
wouldn't drop a ham sandwich first of
all your clone would not be vegan you're
vegan I I mean it depends on what we're
talking about with clones is it an exact
Atomic replica of the me that's sitting
here right now or it something that we
have to grow from a baby I mean I don't
[__] know what sort of Matrix bubble
you're going to pull this damn you know
uh demon out of but all I'm saying is
it's going to
go or maybe like just drinking clam Chow
out of a mug and
then like this just
I and then the the the clam Chow goes
between the mug and drips between his
legs all over his clone penis and into
the toilet water and he's just stick his
head in there going after those clams
and potatoes I can't begin to predict or
take any responsibility for the
behaviors of any of my clones
right will and Chad 13 months ago I told
you that you had six months to get in
the best shape of your lives yeah you
didn't do it so then I gave you another
7 months to get in the best shape of
your lives well time's up I'm curious to
see how you think you both did I want
the ups and the downs and the ins and
the outs I want to hear it all Pals this
is 7 month plan aftermath begin all
right some month plan are you in the
best shape of your life no no me neither
are you no I am not let me ask you this
as a question I know that dudy keeps
hitting us with these xmon plans where
we could to get the best you of our
lives do you think it's even possible
like at this point I will say in the six
and seven-month plan I put in some real
[__] effort yeah me too and I think
there was a point during the seven-month
plan where I was in the best shape of
the seven-month plan and that's about as
much as I can say yeah yeah and that
means nothing because even if you were
just a bag of [__] for the entire 7
months there would have been one day
where you ate a salad and that being the
day that you but I know you comp yeah
but I'm just saying during I'm 47 years
old I I simply don't think it's possible
to get in the best shape of my life
again well I don't want to start a a
conversation that I don't want to have
with you because uh it's been the kind
of topic that we've had on this show and
I'm sure we'll talk about about it again
which is uh hey Chad don't you think
that there's going to be some sort of
medical advancements or like you know AI
health support or whatever that's going
to make and then it's going to inject
little robots into your bloodstream and
make you work out better and all that
sort of [__] so I as I I'm going to
be the Chad clone and
say you will get into the best shape of
your life at 90 I I speed agree with you
like that is possible that there's some
kind of medical advancement uh through
technology that would allow it but I'm
just saying with what I've done in both
the sixth and seven month plan I will
say I go through periods of it like I
was probably in the best shape of the
7mth plan maybe a month or two ago is I
was going to the gym a lot I was taking
creatin I I was seeing some Real Results
feeling strong as [__] then I got sick
for a minute that [__] derails it and
then it's like the holidays come that
derails it it's just so hard to say
consistent and consistency is key in
these things yeah uh I agree and and
uh I let let me take let me uh shoulder
some of that exact same challenge with
you my pal Chow yeah dude I have
struggled my entire life and we know
that you know I've talked about this on
the show and if you know anything about
me uh spring of 1999 to Spring of 2000 I
lost 200 lbs uh did it all uh clean
there was no you know surgery or any of
the the things that some people may uh
go through to deal with their their
bodies my body thankfully as a young man
I was 24 reacted well to this incredible
uh lifestyle change although I grew up
playing sports and did all that stuff I
really didn't know how to eat and I
moved to LA and I gained you know a lot
of over 100 lbs I was always a big boy
but anyway I got real big I lost all the
weight I had an incredible trainer who
saved my life and I had to have two
surgeries to remove skin uh from my body
an upper surgery and a bottom surgery
and they were painful and crazy and
since then I have stayed in the gym
pretty um consistently except for um
there was sort of a five-year period
there and then um I I I started to get
back into the gym my wonderful wife
Molly coming into my life was an
inspiration for that and uh she used to
be a personal trainer and a uh a private
chef and we've had some lifestyle
changes and um it's a bit embarrassing
but I want to be able to you know be
very uh you know uh whatever very clear
you know very truthful about this kind
of [__] the you know it's like I I
people when people have a hard time
eating and I hear from a lot of people
like this I empathize and I always tell
them just get back on the horse the next
day that's all that matters because
sooner or later when you can you know
again I don't want to get into this
stuff I'm just trying to be transparent
um when you love yourself enough you can
you can really make some changes and I
feel like after this year of doing the
the um the seven-month plan came up a
few months ago but we were in the
six-month plan and at the beginning of
2023 I really recommitted myself to not
just being in the gym sometimes but
going three four and five days a week
and I've seen a lot of um uh lot of
development you know with my muscles and
stuff but I'm still a fat bastard uh so
I still you know I'm chubby but I feel
better some of my stats and stuff you
know of course I'm a big dude and I'm 48
and there's pre-diabetic and there's all
this stuff not to bum people out and
talk about all of our problems out there
with health but it's important and what
I'm saying is Chad I hear what you're
saying about just trying to keep it
moving it doesn't always work and I am a
tad embarrassed that I'm not sitting
here well thinned out looking like uh
the the sort of the thinner version of
the big chunky uh will that I am uh
because there's a slightly thinner you
know what I'm saying this is the bane of
my existence um keeping in shape it's
it's a it's a it's a blessing to be able
to uh go to the gym it's wonderful I I
feel very thankful that I can go to the
gym and work on myself and uh so I feel
like we've let uh D down here a little
bit I mean I we anybody no dude please
like you're saying too at our age it's
like it's not going to get [__]
better we can do the best with with our
aging bodies that we have and it really
is just about getting those numbers down
feeling a little better staying mobile
that that really is like all working out
is at this point I will tell you though
the there was a a crystallizing moment
during the seven-month plan where I was
like oh this is it I hit the best shape
of the seven-month plan I was playing
basketball at LA Fitness with a hodg
Podge team of pick up whoever was there
and I got a rebound and I threw a
baseball pass the length of the court to
a guy who's probably 65 years old that
just refused to run back and forth on
the court we were doing full court you
know he would just stay down on the
other end so we would always have four
guys on defense I got this re and I was
just like boom I threw it and it felt
like I was in high school again see uh
that was great that's what's up I I I've
been in the gym pushing up weight you
know what's F we talked about it on the
Show and Chad gross huh you burped
through your nose oh my god dude hey
guys hey let me let me peel the onion a
little bit everybody today it was me
that burped Jesus Christ hold on dude
that's a kayf burp brother you think
it's coming from here it's coming from
there dude they book that bur burp I
booked that burp daddy I'm putting my
hand it's touching your hand in this
hard time blues daddy I've been there
twice I'm coming back Rick Flair Rick N
your boy Flair the thing that I've
started doing Chad is at the beginning
of this year I got back into yoga yeah
my wonderful wife Molly and I have been
taking classes and are oh lulio is
having a Dre I used to do it every day
too having a dream and he's making
little per noises I wish this mic wa all
the way over to him we're going to let
him sleep uh yeah I'm I'm I here's
here's what I can say and for some of
the pods out there POS who have come
with us on this journey I know that some
of you have I know that some of you have
been working uh with us we've sort of
stayed on this thing we sort of haven't
updated much but I got to tell you I
overall I feel better I I am I'm a I'm
guilt driven sometimes okay I'm sorry I
got all sorts of weird any it doesn't
matter We're Here for a Good Time not a
long time and um I'm here to tell you I
feel a net positive after the
seven-month plan and and life is long
let's stay on it let's do it together is
my hand touching your hand in the seven
Monon plan and that's not a world daddy
that's my hand touching your hand I've
been there twice daddy The American
Dream Dusty rods daddy No don't touch my
hand I'm touching my hand through the
screen daddy I've been there twice
daddy I love y'all I'll see you next
time the dusty roads tour 85 n your Boy
Ric Flair there is no
among Thieves I don't know that maybe we
could do an impression optimization with
Dusty Rose maybe no one wants to hear
that yeah I
agree thank you moving on I do think uh
I do think I'm more muscular now than I
was prior to the seven month I did put
on some muscle dude I've been chucking
up weights it's a lot of I miss it it
the density that it gives you it's it's
important for guys of our age you're 47
I'm 48 I'm going to be 49 in May and it
feels good the I had leg day uh
yesterday and I was just put I racked
the [__] thing I dude tossed all I
got the big you know I got the big I got
the big legs and I'm just pushing I'm
doing the leg presses and it's like this
and people like whoa but look at his you
know his big hunky chunky legs and it's
mostly you know it's a lot of genetics
my old man had the big legs you know my
old man had the big legs he had the big
forearms and uh he used to call it the
goose I go Dad show me the goose he go
like bang and there's my dad did that
too the goose yeah he would go look at
this yeah feel like that's [__] steel
he said then he'd whip a baseball at
your head get out yeah you got to go you
become a professional baseball player
I'm going to [__] kill you you know
what my old man used to do in our in our
home gym in our garage it was actually
pretty cool uh dad had a gym in the
garage hello everybody and he uh he used
to put he had a [__] he he you know
bolted to the wall to the studs in the
you know in the wall he bolted a little
piece of 2x4 on that he took a bike tire
folded it drilled that into the [__]
wall he would sit against the wall on
his ass he would take this bike tire
that was yay high head head height and
he would just like work work his neck
out the guy had I mean he stayed in
great shape um even
even before he passed he would
uh he would lift he would lift little
weights and you know he anyway it was it
was incredible uh but to watch him a
statue come to life and do these
exercises that's the journey Daddy I'm
I'm going to get there with you and
that's going to be this hard time blues
I really like doing the dusty road
that's
clear will and Chad you've both had some
interesting conversations about the idea
of free will last week something
interesting happened in dudy after dudy
that I think might shed some light on
the subject I'm going to play a clip
from last week's dudy after dudy for you
and then I want you to discuss what you
both think it means in relation to the
idea of Free Will here's a hint this
segment is called No Free Will here's
the
clip all right I'm back with the
breakdown and I'll be very Frank Chad
has more points by a lot but will I'm
going to do something I've never done
done before I'm going to give you a
chance to make things right after last
week I'm going to ask you a very simple
yes or no question and your answer is
going to determine the winner of today's
episode do you think I made your Hulk
Hogan impression better today yes or
no it's not but it's not about that
that's it's what's that I couldn't quite
hear
you yes
see how easy that was even though it was
AAS you are once again the dudy episode
Champion Chad I'm sure you understand
please hand the hardware I
understand I didn't know that
that please oh [__] that I was not
[__] expecting history has been made
Bobby Heenan and now let's hear a song
about will being a total [__] Mark
for the strap
huh is a mark for the St is a
we is a I'm not taking it back he'll do
anything for that shiny the devil's ass
his way
hell sh and he
[Music]
lik for the is a he's a for the St is a
mark will is a Mark will is a mar will a
Mark that is my favorite song I I was
after hearing it twice that is my
[__] favorite song All right so how
does this relate to Free
Will hey yo oh my God first of all I
just want to say the bad guy Scott Hall
it's uh real clear hey Will don't be a
mark for the strap hey yo we don't care
I never had a problem with Will being a
Mark I never had a problem when I had
the book you know after Kevin Sullivan
gave me the book I had the book for a
while and I said let's give will the
strap I never had a problem with it yeah
so that clip that we just watched in
reference to Free Will how do you think
that that clip displays uh free will or
a lack thereof do you even think it
does uh okay I'm sorry what ask me again
we were played a clip from last week's
dudy after dudy in which you were 100%
manipulated by dudy to say something you
did not want to
say did I not want to say against what
you might perceive as your free will huh
interesting yeah uh I said something and
you're saying I didn't want to say it
that was clear in the video hm clear to
who everyone watching the video I would
say oh and who's saying that me the
person I watched the video I'm one of
the people who watched the video oh are
you one of of the people who watched the
video or are you all of the people who
watched the video okay my apologies you
okay I'll just say the objective truth
dudy asked you if you thought uh its
impression optimization helped your
impression and you said well I don't
really think it's about that that to me
is a clear indication you didn't want to
say yes and then dudy said sorry
couldn't hear that you said yeah cuz you
thought that would help you win the belt
and indeed it did mhm yeah I got the
belt and you believe that's free will
look
as we all as I love to say on the show
and it's you know and when we talk when
we talk about what we're talking about
we're talking about D they holding the
book Daddy and I'm going to tell you
this D dud the works in mysterious ways
daddy oh look he's finding another spot
to lul do you think he has free will I
do think sweet lulio has free will I
watch Lully do look in order for us to
talk about this okay and the whole Free
Will thing because the only knowledge I
have of free will versus determinism and
some of the stuff that I know about it I
only know very tangentially because of
my pal Chow here sending me an article
here or there in our lives out of this
room saying hey here's here's check this
out now do you still think of Free Will
so if if you could Chad yeah please uh
give me and some of our audience out
there an argument against free will uh
that that some what scientific or at
least
philosophically uh Jing with what's
happening most recently with what what
what um people you know smart people and
scientists are saying I would say there
are a bunch of different attacks on the
notion of Free Will from various uh
areas in science there's like physics
you can say if the Big Bang was real or
I mean who knows if that's true now
either a lot of shit's getting shaken up
there but basically that particles were
sent on some kind of a trajectory at
some point they coales to form planets
Stars ultimately human beings and our
minds but that initial trajectory of
those particles cannot be changed MH and
that was it so everything was set in
motion at that point and nothing we we
do is outside of that jurisdiction even
beyond that sorry I am sorry to
interrupt yeah well I'm sorry to
interrupt dude I I I I will subscribe to
that I will give you that because that
is some [__] science and people in white
lab Cod and stuff so wait a minute
you're you're agreeing then there's no
Free Will based on that no I'm just
agreeing that the neutrons and the
protons and the atoms and all the little
particles all the stuff yeah that has
shot out from The Big Bang I don't
understand that I don't understand I
cannot understand how many times have I
told you that you know luminous beings
are we sure not this crude matter right
so I I will I will give you that that
there's there's stuff we can't see and
it's pushing out into the into existence
and um there are forces that are um that
make us who we are and give us our
experience of life before we're even
around but those things Earth was even
around yeah there's before any stars or
anything was even around that's kind of
like that part of that's physics yeah
and and you also start to get into
biology of like we are just comprised of
cells and atoms and those things behave
in certain fundamental ways that like we
don't have any conscious control over
right um there is also though Behavioral
Science and this is I think the the kind
of most easiest concept to grasp in
terms of an argument against free will
is that basically your brain is just a a
thing that develops in reaction to your
environment to uh the interactions you
have with other people there's a little
bit of genetics in there so it's a
little bit of nurture it's a little bit
of nature it's some uh you know really
unquantifiable amount of a combination
of both of those things but by a certain
point in your life this thing is [__]
cooked and it's just a program that
tells you how to react to anything and
everything you're ever going to
encounter for the rest of your life and
that's what we that that I think is like
the again the easiest way to digest this
the easiest way to understand it is by
the time you're around seven or eight
you're essentially done and and every
Behavior you have after that is going to
be just in reaction to things and even
before that but once you're seven or
eight you you really have all the
information you need to have built your
um program of reactions to the world
that you will encounter okay let me go
all the way to a horrible example uh
someone who is a murderer they have uh
decided to pull the trigger they are
making a a horrible choice to end
another person's life you're telling me
and I'm using the most extreme example
for a reason you're telling me that a
seven or eight-year-old that that that
was predetermined because of their
experience whatever base they were on
when they were born based on who their
par parents are what their experience is
what the environment is yes that's what
I'm telling you no it's half and half
it's half and half you can think what
you want I'm telling you what scientists
are saying as well this isn't just my
opinion this is uh every scientist Chad
no obviously not every scientist people
who study Behavioral
Science big ones in these fields are all
kind of like agreeing with this and
baseball's an interesting an say Roman
Reigns of scientists is saying this I
don't know who that or would you say the
LA Knight of scientist is saying this
it's the LA KN of scientist saying this
or is it the Jade Carill it's probably
the Jade it's probably all of them
rolled into one I'll also take your
baseball analogy and go down that path
if you'll come with me take somebody
like a pro baseball player yeah when
you're I I played baseball for many
years of my life training for baseball
is essentially training your brain to
have no Free Will at all it's pure
reaction to whatever's happening in the
game so when you swing at a baseball
you're not thinking like oh [__] here it
comes I let me think if it's a curveball
and then I'll make a quick decision on
whether or not I want to swing This Bat
it's just reaction there's nothing there
same thing if they hit you a ground ball
if they hit you a Fly ball any of that
[__] it's just reaction all sports are
that you're training your brain on a a
limited scale with limited rules in a
limited environment to Simply react
quicker and better than everyone else
who's who's playing under those same
circumstances if you just extrapolate
that out to life the world it's the same
thing you're training your brain to just
react quickly in these things to have
the best reactions you can for the
outcomes and quotes you want so we're
just biological machines your brain is
trained you have no free will we're just
a bunch of dumb rats in a cage hey I'm
I'll give you that I don't really
understand this [__] and maybe I can't
wrap my head around it but I can say
very confidently you're wrong cuz I
decide to do all sorts of [__] all the
[__] time that's an illusion this
morning I made an omelet M yeah you know
what I put in the omelet yeah what I uh
well I put some little turkey slices in
there have you ever done that
before yeah and you like it yeah it good
so you're just going to keep doing the
thing you like yeah I like that but
here's the Ripple why didn't you wake up
this morning and build a
spaceship because I it's something I
wouldn't be able to do unless I've had a
healthy breakfast oh I see you were
getting ready to build a spaceship yeah
here's the variable here's the here's
the twist this is what I would say if I
were in a big lecture room like in
Goodwill Hunting I'm at M it and I'm
teaching I've got like a scarf and
everything oh nice dude yep um I would
say uh students this morning I woke up
and I had my omelette I put some little
turkey slices in it but you know what
else I added I added a little cottage
cheese oh [__] which is I know it's a
little weird to put that in the but I
don't eat like you know shitty have
done yeah then you like it yeah I like
it it's good so you do it again yeah but
today we had some have you ever put
something in there you didn't like in
the omelet yeah all the time and do you
still keep putting it in there the same
thing you don't
like sometimes that's just cuz if it's
the only thing that is around in the
fridge and I just finished explaining
that I have a problem you don't like
well you've never even eaten anything
out of the toilet you're disqualified
from this conversation my point is this
I also put some salsa on the [__]
look the point is we're not going to get
to the end of this [__] today uh no
nor will we ever this will be a
conversation well then what the [__] are
we even talking about it and how do you
think that you're right and I'm wrong I
just decided to yell daddy and my hand
is touching your hand and we're yelling
about omelets and cottage cheese Daddy
it's a very runny cheese daddy Rick
Flair the Four Horsemen you better run
from this omelet Daddy because you took
me out but now with your help I am back
and and I'm going to make another
omelette next morning Daddy because let
me tell you something I may not look
like the athlete of the day my belly
just a little too big my honey just a
little too big daddy but I am bad and
they know I'm bad I love
you thank you moving on nailed that shut
yeah that's guys we did it the big 90
hope you're feeling good I know I am you
scored a total of 76 points today now
you have
8,431 overall points you're only
1,569 points away from the magic number
10,000 you're going to love what happens
but we've got a little time before we
get there and I heard what you had to
say about the seven-month plan so I've
decided that today we're starting the
dudy 8mon plan this is going to be a
little different though I hear what
you're saying about the difficulty of
sticking to the routine so I'm going to
help you out every month is going to be
a different Focus it's simplified the
first month of the dudy 8mon challenge
is flexibility February every day this
month you each have to do 30 minutes of
yoga minimum I think you're going to be
astonished by the results that's hard
that sounds like fun look I've already
been doing yoga but 30 minutes of yoga a
day every day for the month of February
hard dude that ain't hard I'll tell you
why it's not hard cuz I I am uh there
used to be a workout that I used to do
uh from the speaking of Cody rhods a man
who is family to the roads family the
incredible uh the inspirational Diamond
Dallas Page of course has DDP Yoga I
used to do DDP Yoga um and and I love
DDP Yoga and there's a particular in his
first workout I used to do it on the the
DVDs you know and his one of his first
workouts was uh workout DDP yoga
packages there was a a 30-minute workout
called fat burner that I did so many
times that I essentially had it
memorized
and it was really good and while I was
doing a lot of yoga this is now seven
years ago again embarrassing but I'm GNA
do I'm yeah I'm gonna get with some DDP
Yoga I don't know what I'm going to do
maybe yoga with Adrian what's yoga with
Adrien a big Youtube yoga instructor and
then that's Adrien yeah yeah all right
yo Adrian you remember that that's
another impression yeah I remember yeah
you want to come you come on stinks you
want a little B move you want stinks
remember
Rocky stinks it's Rocky dude thanks to
everyone who joined us this week I can't
wait to see you again next week until
then call me dudy too many
[Music]
[Applause]
Impressions yeah lights go down I'm
ready now tear this roof off for the
town going to give them what they came
to to
see hear the crowd on their toes ready
for me to St the show the C lights go up
I'm home
W that's the second verse of uh Cody
rhod's theme song Welcome to dudy after
dudy you know what I mean it's just a
chill hang after the show it's the time
after the show yeah and and uh just like
uh Cody R's theme song the lights have
gone down indeed and you're going to
want to head over to patreon.com dudy
obviously to join us on dudy plus dudy
after dudy and we're having a good time
you know might spark up some Gabus and
it's just me we're going to have a good
time hanging out as we do a couple of
onew dudes [__]
around welcome to dudy after dudy the
flagship weekly show of dudy Plus
available only at patreon.com dudy will
Will's Free Will Will him another belt
win or will Chad's radical ideas about
determinism be enough to win it back
stay tuned to find out this is dudy
after dudy have some fun with it for
Christ's
sake all right yes sir um let me ask you
a question okay you watch any football
this weekend yeah I did I watched some
football did you see who who won who was
one of the winning teams I'm picking up
what you're laying down you're talking
about the Kansas City Chiefs that's who
I'm talking about they're going to the
big dance yeah did you see who was at
the
game was it Taylor Swift it was uh
Taylor Swift okay yeah mhm and did you
know
that Taylor Swift is going to be
performing a concert in Japan the night
before the Super Bowl nope I did not
know that if that's your question I did
know that and what it means is she's
going to have a window of time to take a
flight immediately after her concert fly
12 hours back to the United States
against the time zones Landing in Las
Vegas at 5:00 p.m. the day before the
Super Bowl giving her 25 hours 35
minutes to uh do something do you know
what that means if you
like tell a
friend if you like d what you
do please tell a friend
thenie if you like
d please tell a friend then